let's explore another example of a
binomial distribution let's say i'm
playing basketball and i don't know i
know i'm going to take 10 shots in the
game so i'm going to take 10 shots let's
say that n is equal to 10
that's the number of shots i take and
oh let's just say that every shot i take
at their independent events and that in
general i have a thirty percent shot
chance of making any given basket we're
not going to get too detailed of where i
take the basket from or the
three-pointers or they lay out whatever
every time i take a shot i have a thirty
percent chance of making it so say the
probability of success
is equal to thirty percent
probability is equal to thirty percent i
just made that definition and let's say
let's define a a random variable x
like we always do
x
is equal to
number
of shots i make
number of shots baskets i make and this
was a little bit more interesting than
the
then the
the the flipping a coin example because
in the flipping of coin example heads or
tails both had an equal probability of
happening
in this situation making a shot is less
likely than not making a shot right the
the not making a shot let's say not
not making a shot that is equal to 1
minus the probability of making a shot
which is equal to 70 percent so the
slight twist on what we did before but
in some ways this might be a more
interesting example to your everyday
life and let's see what the distribution
looks like and also i'm taking more
shots now than i did before
and so it'll probably take a little bit
more time actually this is too much
let's because i want to i don't want to
waste too much time let's do let's say i
take six shots and x the random variable
x is the number of shots i make
so let's think about how we figure out
this probability what is the probability
what is the probability that
x
is equal to zero
so i make no shots at all so i take six
shots and every shot i take i miss so in
order for that to happen
this event has to happen
six times in a row
so something with the seventy percent
probability has to happen
six times in a row the probability of
this is
point seven right that's seventy percent
times point seven times point seven
times point
point seven
i'm getting confused it's point seven
times 0.7 times 0.7 times 0.7 times 0.7
times 0.7 right each of these are
missing the first shot second shot third
shot and so forth and so on and this is
equal to 0.7 to the
sixth power whatever that might be
all right and there's only one way to do
it i literally have to miss every shot
in order for x to be equal to zero
what's the probability that i make
exactly
one shot
so
well what's what's the probability i i
might make the first one and then miss
the other ones i might make miss all of
them but the second i might miss all of
them but the third so let's think about
what's the probability of each of those
circumstances so if i
let's say i make it i'll call that a
make too bad make and miss both start
with m
let's see if i
i'll call it point
point and miss right so it could be like
a point and then
five misses
five misses it could be a miss
a miss a miss a point a miss a miss as
you can imagine there's five of these
scenarios right i could just in in one
of there's actually six of these
scenarios right this my point the shot
that i make would be in one of these six
i don't want to use the word bucket
because we're already using a basket or
using a basketball analogy but it can be
in one of these six spots in one of the
six shots that i take right so there's
six of these scenarios what's the
probability of each of these this is
going to be equal this is a 30 percent
chance of happening and then the the
each of these are 70 chance of happening
right so it'd be point three
times
point seven times point seven times
point seven times point seven times
point seven this is point seven to the
fifth right times point seven to the
fifth that's the odds of this happening
what are the odds of this one happening
well you see you have 0.7 times 0.7
times 0.7 times 0.3 times 0.7 times 0.7
but if you think about it you're still
taking 0.7 times itself five times right
0.7.7.7
0.7.7
you're taking 0.7 to the fifth power and
you have to multiply by 0.3 once as well
so no matter where you make the shot the
chances of
any of these permutations independently
or 0.3 times 0.7 to the fifth whatever
that is and then how many ways are there
to do this well we just figured out
there's six ways to do this right you
might make only the first shot you might
make only the second shot only the third
shot and so forth and so on so the
probability that x is equal to one
the probability that our random variable
is equal to one is equal to
six
times point three times point seven
to the fifth and just so that we make it
clear and connect it all to the binomial
distribution what would be the what
would have been the if we would have
done the you know n choose zero here
what's the binomial coefficient so in
our example n is six
so what's 6 choose 0
6 choose 0 that's 6 factorial
6 factorial
over
over
0 factorial
times six minus zero factorial
six minus zero factorial
six minus zero is just six so six
factorial divided by six factorial those
cancel out you're just with the one well
what's zero factorial and this is one of
those bizarre definitional things in
mathematics and i'll leave you to think
about it and i've addressed this in
previous videos but zero factorial is
actually actually so that it works out
properly is defined to be equal to one
and i did that to just show you that
this is the binomial coefficient on this
term right so we just multiply it by one
that's why i never even brought it up
the probability of this happening is .7
to the sixth and then you multiply it
times the binomial coefficient but
there's only one way that this can
happen and that's why this cap turned
out to be 1. i didn't want to confuse
you so i didn't bring all that up but we
did still use the binomial coefficient
let's think about it in this one in this
situation
we're taking six shots
and we're choosing only one of them to
be made
with six choose one
that's six factorial
over
one factorial
divided by six minus one factorial six
minus one factorial
that's six factorial divided by well one
factor we can ignore that's just one
divided by five factorial
what's that that's six times five times
four times three times one divided by
five times four times three times one so
everything else cancels out except for
just for the 6's and so that's where we
got our 6 from and we got it by
reasoning which actually i think is a
better way to get it but i just want to
show you that we're still using the
binomial coefficients this is 6 choose 1
and then we multiply that times the
probability of any of these permutations
happening and we figure that out by
one we make one shot and we miss the
rest
let's keep going
i think you'll hope you'll get the hang
of this
sooner than later
what's the probability that you make
exactly two shots
so what's the probability for any given
let's say you know let's say i make
let's say i miss
miss
miss
miss and then i get two points or two
shots i don't want to get too confused
let's say they're all worth one point
this this version of basketball we're
playing so here what's the probability
if point seven times point seven times
point seven times point seven times
point three times point three
right so this is 0.7 to the 1 2 3 4
power
times 0.3
squared
right
that's each of these circumstances but
this isn't the only way that i can make
two shots in i can pick essentially i
can choose any two of these shots i take
to be the ones that i make i'm not
picking it but the
gods of probability will pick it right
so that this isn't the only circumstance
the probability of just this
circumstance where i miss exactly the
last two shots is this
but if i wanted to figure out all of the
different
ways that i can make exactly two shots
i'm i would essentially say well i'm
taking six shots and i'm choosing two of
them to be made so how many does that
result in let's see six factorial
over two factorial
over six minus two factorial that is
equal to i like to multiply it out
that's six times five times three times
two times one
over two times one
divide this is four factorial right six
minus two is four factorials four times
three times two times one and actually i
forgot to write a four up here six times
5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1.
anyway
this cancels out with that
the 2 and the 6 is 3 so it becomes 15.
so there are 15 possible ways
to make exactly two shots especially if
you don't care about the order in which
which you know i'm not saying that
you know this point and this point if
they were to happen the other way around
it doesn't matter it's kind of the same
circumstance right it's the same
i made the last two shots it doesn't say
i made the second to last shot in one
way and i made the last shot in the
other way we're not differentiating
between we're just saying that we made
them
right so that's why there's 15 different
ways to make two shots out of six and
the probability of each of those is 0.7
to the fourth
.7 to the fourth times .3 squared so the
probability of making exactly two shots
is going to be
six choose two
times point seven to the fourth
times
point three
squared
and we can go on let's let's do them
fast the probability that i make
exactly
three shots by the same logic what's the
probability that i make exactly in any
one of the circumstance well how many
ways can i make three shots well i'm
taking six and i'm choosing three
and then the probability of each of
those ways is
in order to make three shots i'm going
to miss three shots and then i'm going
to make three shots
straight that's straightforward enough
and we could calculate what that is
but hopefully you know let's see let me
just do it so that's 6 factorial
that's six factorial over
three factorial times six minus three
factorial times this part point seven
third times point three squared
let's keep going and this should
actually
it gets faster once you see probability
that i make exactly four shots well i'm
taking six and i'm going to make four of
them so i have to choose four out of six
so if i'm making four shots i'm missing
two shots
so there's going to be two shots that i
miss point seven times point seven
that's the probability of a miss point
seven
and then i'm making four of them so
point three there's a thirty percent
chance of making each of them
so to make four
point three to the fourth so in any one
of these ways where i make four shots
this is their probability and there are
this many ways of doing it and that's
equal to
six factorial over
over
4 factorial times 6 minus 4
factorial and then times .7 squared
times 0.3
to the fourth and if you think this is 2
factorial right this is 2 factorial and
we figured out what that was up here
right 6 choose 2 was the same thing it
was 6 factorial over 2 factorial divided
by 4 factorial
it's the same thing as this we just
switched the 4s and the 2s so this would
also be equal to 15.
anyway i'll probably do that in the next
video but let's just calculate these
really fast
the probability that x is equal to five
i make five shots that's
six choose five
times .7
so i'm only missing one shot right so
the probability of missing one is 0.7
and then i have to make five not
necessarily in a row
point three to the fifth but you see
each of the ways any given way that i
make exactly five shots
this is the probability
and there are this many ways six choose
five ways of making exactly five shots i
could get the first five shots missed
the six i could get the last five shots
i could make the first miss the second
etcetera and so forth
and then finally the probability that x
is equal to six i make all of the shots
that's six choose six how many ways can
i pick six things out of six
choices and there's really only one way
you could calculate it by calculating
that and once again you'll have to you
you'll have to know that zero factorial
is equal to one and i have to make all
six shots so point three to the sixth
right point three times point three
times point three times point three
anyway i'm all out of time again in the
next video we're going to graph this